Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Boys
Gen V Episode 4 video
Big Tek Knight episode.
They finally did the Tek
Knight character,
probably one of the biggest degenerates
in the boys universe, but not quite
the psychopath that Homelander is.
there are a bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes cable
for spoilers of the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs
WTF moments in all the parodies of Marvel
and DC characters, starting
with the episode title The Whole Truth,
The name of Tek Knights TV show.
It's also a pun about his proclivities,
the whole idea that he's obsessed
with holes because of his brain tumor.
So the whole idea is that yes,
he is a degenerate.
He does all these things.
He tries to stick it
in every hole that he can find.
That's
basically what he does in the comics.
It winds up getting him into all kinds
of trouble that Vought has to cover up.
But the difference between him
and like another deviant, like Homelander,
for instance, is it
Homelander is like a full blown psychopath
and knows what he's doing is bad.
whereas in the comics,
everything the Tek Knight is doing
is caused by the brain tumor.
That's to blame for all the craziness.
it's mainly a Tek Knight episode
and they lean very heavily into the Batman
side of his parody.
The whole idea is that the character in
the comics is meant to be a parody of both
Batman and Iron Man like he is a Tek, as
in Iron Man Night, as in The Dark Knight.
one of the big differences
with the character
and they make fun of him in the episode
for this
is that he is not a compound vs superhero.
He doesn't have compound B
he uses Teknology to make himself
a superhero like Iron Man and Batman.
the showrunner
said that they lean more heavily
into the Batman side of the character
just because it was more ripe
for this kind of parody.
Like his investigative journalism
is a parody on Batman being the world's
greatest detective, end, in the episode,
they make Tek Knight's
abilities seem kind of like Sherlock's
deduction capabilities,
learning things just from basic clues,
not actually having superpowers.
within the world of the boys,
they mention the character
a bunch of different times
back to season one
they didn't say if he's still on the team,
but originally
he used to be on the payback team
when it was led by Stormfront.
during the events of season one,
they have starlight
joining the seventh to fill
the spot left by translucent after he dies
Originally Tek Knight
was meant to join the seven.
But what happened
is that he actually tried
to get with his teammates
while they were flying in midair
because of his proclivities.
His obsession with holes.
He tries to get with them
and in immediately
they kick him off the team, losing his bid
to actually join the seven.
They said on the TV show
he will have his sidekick Eladio.
That's meant to be a version of Robin
like, you know, Batman Robin parody.
He also has a version of Alfred
the Butler.
Or you could say Jarvis
because Iron Man has a Jarvis Butler.
in the actual
opening scene when they're investigating
the aftermath of Sam and Emma's escape,
they make another Tekno
comic book reference to
when the doctor thinks
that Sam stuck it in the guard's ear
and killed him
that way with a super strain,
that's actually a reference to something
the Tek Knight did to his butler,
His version of Alfred in the comics.
one of the differences
with this version of the character
is that he
didn't have the TV show in the comics.
He was just a super rich person
who used his Teknology
to become a superhero On Vaughn's
payback team and he didn't
go to this particular school
like he did in the world of the TV show.
I think part of the joke on the TV
shows the good doctor is only meant
to admit compound these superhero kids.
And they admitted him 20 years ago
when he was a kid
because he bought his way
in with his money
normally Vought wouldn't care about non
superhero children.
had the show leaned in more the Iron Man
direction of his parody character,
they probably would have made him more
like a crazy Elon Musk type of person.
And they already kind of
did that with Homelander taking over.
But they even just did a promo
where Homelander takes over
a social media platform,
then fires everyone, which is a direct
parody of Elon Musk buying Twitter,
then firing most of the employees
The funny thing about the boys TV show
is that like, crazier, crazier stuff
keeps happening in real life, giving them
material to parody on the TV show.
Like the TV show
keeps getting crazy and crazier
Because people in real life
keep getting crazier and crazier.
but the whole idea with this opening
scene is
the dean is trying
to figure out a way to cover this up
because she thinks that VOD
is going to kill her and possibly worse.
The whole idea is that Vought is looking
to cover everything up and find a patsy
if things do go wrong in a public way,
like if something gets caught on camera,
like one of the kids does
something in the news, finds out about it,
but we'll just pin it on the dean.
she also makes that joke
about doing it with schools.
They pay off that joke
with Tek Knight later in the episode
when he actually literally tries
to do that to a school in her office.
The doctor also says
that Sam is much stronger than Golden Boy.
Most superheroes, in addition
to their main special powers,
get a bunch of extra low level ones,
do like the ability to hear greater
amount of frequencies than the human ear.
They can heal a little bit faster.
They're a little bit stronger,
a little bit faster moving.
but it sounds like they're trying to say
that Sam is much closer to like Queen
May's level of power.
And she used to be like the second
most powerful person on the seven
next to Homelander until Ryan came along.
She's not quite as strong,
but she's close.
Like she could match him briefly.
meaning that Sam is crazy powerful.
He also makes a bunch of Hulk jumps later
in the episode, so he's strong.
Kind of like the Hulk
And either he's insane
or there's something else
that Vought did to mess with his mind
because he keeps seeing Jason Ritter
in a Sesame Street
and Avenue Q parody with the deep puppet
in a bunch of other puppets
we've seen in the trailer
whose gills talk in this puppet
hallucination,
that's meant to pay off the joke
from an earlier season
of The Boys, where Patton Oswalt played
the voice of deep gills.
When they anthropomorphize them
like the Deep had a conversation
with his gills.
some of you also asked about the animals
on the walls here in the woods.
They look similar to the animals
that Blackmore hallucinated.
It's possible
he also spent time in the woods
at some point, but I think the idea is
a school was created after he had already
become active in those flashbacks.
They also confirmed during the episode
here that Dean is not a superhero.
She doesn't
have compound these superpowers
Then the Scooby Gang finds Emma's tracker,
and Andre's
right on the money with his theory
that Sam just uses super strength to jump
super
far like the Hulk
instead of running at super speed
in that created the craters, the impact
from his landings and take offs.
then, even though the kid's all kind
of low level, can't stand each other,
they want them to seem
like they're becoming more of a team.
Slowly, they're slowly coming together
and even make a literal Scooby
Doo reference with the Green band,
quote unquote, The Mystery Machine.
They still are that whole ranking subplot.
I don't really care too much about it,
and it seems like most of the kids
on the show don't actually care about it,
except for the Jordan Lee character.
Like, who cares
who's number one? Who's number two?
the Mengele reference she makes in
the woods is about a
doctor during World War Two in real life,
which is ironic
because even though Jordan doesn't know
the true history of the company, Vought,
the founder of the company, was originally
a German scientist during World War Two.
He developed Compound V for the Germans,
it on his wife, who became Stormfront.
Then he came to the United States with her
After the war through Operation Paperclip
developed Vought American and continue
to build the company around compound these
superheroes, experimenting on Americans.
Now that's where soldier Boy basically
came from Jensen Ackles character.
He was the first attempt to create an
American superhero during World War Two.
basically a parody of Captain America's
origin story, like a dirt bag
version of Captain America.
and even though Jensen Ackles
got put into cryo
during season three of the boys, he's
going to cameo again during the Gen
V episodes at some point in there actually
a couple of moments in the episode
where you see Soldier Boy on old movie
posters from back in the eighties.
Maybe they included some flashback
with his character,
or maybe he filmed some of those funny
parody videos like Captain America
did in Spider-Man Homecoming
that all the students have to watch
they're couple promo videos
that they did for him like that
when they introduced the character
Hello, I'm Soulja Boy.
The world knows who I am.
What do I have to say it?
Who approved this script? Stan Edgar.
If taking drugs is uncool,
I'm the most uncool on the planet.
you. Okay, great.
then the kids start to figure out
that all the faculty,
the Dean Brink, were behind the woods.
They're all on bots payroll
because the school was created by Vought.
the whole idea in Buffy is
the school is built on a Hellmouth.
the Vought School is built on an evil
laboratory.
there's a little dissension in the group.
It makes me wonder if some of the kids
are going to betray the others in exchange
for Vought
giving them a pass when they come to kill,
whoever steps out of line
like Vought will want to control whatever
situation this winds up turning into in.
At worst, they'll just kill everybody.
right
now, Kate is at the top of my betrayal
as she seems
that she really doesn't want to care about
Sam or Emma or the other kids.
They also keep hyping up this relationship
between her and Andre
like he needs her so badly.
Now he's breaking down, I think, to make
her potential betrayal hit way harder.
now, it seems like his arc is him slowly
becoming more of an actual superhero,
like he wants to be an actual superhero
and use his powers for good.
So I think the idea is that
by the end of the series,
some of the kids will be a little bit
more like Butcher in the Boys
and want to stop Vought,
Emma and Sam
make it to the drive in movie theater
that Sam used to visit with Golden Boy
when they were younger.
they're a couple more Ant-Man jokes
about Emma's powers and growing
because she actually ate
some of the guard's brains
when she passed through them.
this is also to set up the giant man
joke later
in the episode
when she's eats more food to grow.
Super huge
they start shipping the
to the characters like they'll have
some kind of relationship eventually.
I don't mind some of this,
but there are a few moments
during the episode where
sort of to stray into CW Riverdale
kind of territory
with the scenes
between the different pairings.
They handle the relationships
a little bit better.
On the Boys main series,
I think like Hughie and Starlight end,
in the case
of dysfunctional relationships.
Homelander in every woman
that he's ever been with, they also joke
that that's one of homelander's
actual weaknesses
milk and women basically
like they just completely confound him.
Sam has severe abandonment issues stemming
from his compound powers and everything
he's been through in his young life.
most of the episode,
though, is Emma trying to talk him down
before the others can hurt him or worse?
Vought
just shows that to try and kill him,
normally Vought would either try
to kill a problem like this,
like they just wipe you off the map
completely in a doused in Lysol,
if you're too powerful to kill,
they just put you in cryo
because there are a lot of superheroes
that are like that.
They're just so strong that no matter
how you hurt them, they won't die.
that's why they put Jensen Ackles Soldier
Boy in cryo because he's too powerful
to actually kill in
Stormfront had to kill herself,
although Homelander could have done it.
this gets into something that
they haven't done in the TV shows yet.
They might save this
for like a future season,
but you can actually use compound B
to bring people back from the dead.
Vought does that in the comics,
but when they do that
usually people who come back from death
are completely mindless.
They lose their mental capacity
basically turning into zombified drones.
they have a funny promo for tonight's
TV show, The Whole Truth Notice
during the promo,
they flash a bunch of circles
and holds more references to his king.
Pretty much every sentence that he utters
has some a pun about holes
Notice of the TV show airs on Vought Plus,
which is a parody of Disney.
Plus,
they did a much larger promo parodying
Disney Plus
when it launched a couple of years ago.
the other joke of his TV show,
the whole truth is that
it is actually the opposite of the truth.
He says point blank he's
going to cover up anything he needs to.
For Vought and pin Golden Boy's
death on a patsy in
his whole show is based on doing stuff
like this all over the place,
just creating fake stories
that are better for ratings.
semi might recognize the actor tonight
as played by Derek Wilson.
He was on Future Man in Preacher.
He was hilarious on Future Man.
He was totally crazy character.
there's even more puns about him
plunging himself into holes then,
even when he's practicing his vocals with
a little rhyme about the slithered sheet,
that sounds like it's
another reference to his King.
they have another funny moment
when he has a confrontation
with the dean in her office.
And even though he tries to play it
like he's there and she's afraid,
really, like she pauses for a bit
because she knows about his king.
She knows she's getting him on camera
in case she needs to have any dirt
on him to protect herself
And I think she was waiting
to go into her office because she wasn't
sure if she was going to catch him
in the act of humping something.
but while they're talking, you can see him
fingering holes all over the place,
like making little circles
with his finger on everything.
end, even though she's a little bit
worried about Teknique,
she's more worried about Vaught
getting pissed off like Ashley
calling a hit on her, basically, or
pinning everything on her
and then burying her in deep, dark hole.
because that is bots M.O.
Like if there's a big problem,
they'll just pin it on
someone like they did with Stormfront
at the end of season two.
Like, oh, it was all her fault.
She did this all by herself.
Nobody else was involved with it.
when the dean says iron class
killed himself after being interrogated
by Tek nine, he's
meant to be a parody of Marvel's iron
clad character who was an evil counterpart
of the thing from Fantastic Four.
Pretty much everybody in the boys
universe is either like a marvel parody
or a DC parody character They featured
the iron clad character during that boy's
diabolical animated series.
It was a solid series,
but there were a bunch of
different episodes
featuring different adventures.
He basically has skin made of metal
in the Boys, and Butcher targeted him
because he drank people's
blood in order to cure his EDI.
another weird kink related problem
they probably use the iron clad reference
on the show because of his unique
kink in Tek Knight's unique kink
very phallic episode just in general
when she says most of his subjects
wind up dead
after he investigates them, it's
because Vought either
has them killed to cover something up
or he himself kills them.
They show off
some of his Sherlock abilities,
deducing that she's lying, figuring out
some legit information about Sam's escape,
showing you
that he does actually have some abilities.
But they're not superpowers.
they reference Ashley and Vought Corporate
because Tek Knights TV show is basically
just a front for Vought to clean up
messes like this and then cover them up
Tek Knight makes the Johnny Depp reference
when he says that he's going to frame
someone for everything that happened.
Most of you probably understood
that reference fairly recent thing
that just happened last year,
the boys really likes to be current
on all their parodies.
they do another funny promo for
Take Nights
TV show telling a story about Sheehy
Smith, who's a parody of Marvel She-Hulk,
who apparently killed her lover
when they were doing it.
Because you super huge and strong.
That's a common thing
with superheroes, too.
They make a bunch of jokes about it
during season one.
There's even a super
support group for people that were injured
while doing it with superheroes.
Marie tries to get help from Rufus, who
has psychic powers in astral projection.
He's played by Alexander Calvert
from Supernatural.
I believe he became the new version of God
by the end of that series.
But on the Boys, he's
basically a pervert in messing with Marie,
trying to have his way with her,
using his powers
until she explodes his junk.
What a way to go.
But the supernatural connection
is that the showrunner of the boys,
the main show,
actually created the supernatural show.
So that's all the supernatural actors
are winding up on.
The boys like Jensen,
Ackles, Richard Singer.
They have Jeffrey Dean Morgan coming to
the boys Season four as another character.
All we need now is Jared Padalecki
let me know in the comments
who you think he should play on the boys
the thing with roofies too,
is that most compound these superheroes on
the boys are total perverts.
Some worse than others, though.
And usually Vought tries
to cover everything up for them,
which is probably how Roufus wound up
at that campus not being arrested?
normally somebody like that
would get thrown in jail a lot quicker.
really good example
that is Homelander with Becca
and Ryan Vought basically covered that up,
even covering it up from Homelander
so that he wouldn't learn about Ryan.
Tekno interviews,
all the kids, starting with Andre
and his father until he loses it.
It makes fun of Tek for not actually
having compound these superpowers.
probably the craziest moment
during all the student interviews
was when take night smells
Kate's body on Andre's mouth in the way
he also reveals that to saying
he was eating
holds more to Tek Knight's obsession
with holes.
back of the drive in movie
theater, the Red Thunder two movie
poster is for a payback movie with Jensen
Ackles soldier boy in their team.
It looks like it was from the eighties,
like an eighties action movie.
Sylvester Stallone or Schwarzenegger
would have made Sam starts
hearing the voices
of the puppets in his head,
but we don't actually see them till later,
and it's going to get even crazier,
I think, in future episodes.
had the superhero branding class.
Obviously,
the joke here is the whole college
is basically like a social media college
teaching the kids
how to create brands around themselves
and develop big social media followings,
not actually teaching them
how to say people
because he doesn't really care
about actually saving people.
Tonight interrogates
Marie in front of everyone, successfully
getting her to confess the truth
about what happened
with Golden Boy dying and Jordan
being the real hero in the real reason.
It seems like
he doesn't want to pin Golden Boy's
death on the students and wants to.
Dean instead is probably
because Vought told him to do that.
the whole idea being that the kids
could potentially become big money
earners for Vought someday,
whereas she could not.
And they can just replace her
with another person
to raise money for the college
with those fake fundraisers.
that was also the reason they were going
to kick Marie out of school.
Like these are the kids.
They have potential to be big money
earners.
For Vought you do not Back at the drive
in, when Sam is looking out the window,
zoom in hands on the newspapers here
covering the windows.
It has Soulja Boy and payback on them.
This is Crimson Countess.
I think the idea is the driving
closed sometime during the 2000s
when Sam and Golden Boy
would have been kids.
So these seem like really old newspapers.
Then they have that wicked Sesame Street
parody hallucination.
It's also a parody of Avenue Q like Avenue
V for Vought is weird as it gets.
It's also notable that he calls
Jason Ritter by his name as if real, like
Jason Ritter is now keen into the boys
universe.
Like there's an actor named Jason Ritter
that just works for Vought.
butt in the scene, he's meant to be a
parody of Mister Rogers with the sweater.
It also they have the puppet of the deep
and the gills.
Talking is a reference back to a joke from
an earlier season of the Boys main show
where the Deep talked to his gills,
but they were in his mind But.
The voice of his gills were played by
Patton Oswalt, and it was all in his head.
For the most part, the way they play
this is is Sam's own fractured
mind telling him to do this
like he is genuinely insane.
But there could be something that Vought
did this causing him to do this.
Like they could be doing something
shady on the side.
Do he winds up doing super jumps taking
off like the hulk to go kill the doctor
then the dean
Turn things around on Tek Knight,
revealing all the footage in the montage
she has of him humping every hole in sight
and his brain tumor.
Now, I don't know how many episodes Tek
Night is supposed to be in this season,
but in the comics,
the way he goes out was hilarious.
It was crazy.
He thinks he's saving the world
from a giant meteorite
trying to blow it up
while sticking his junk in
when really that was just a hallucination
because of his brain tumor
and he was killed
by a falling wheelbarrow.
my assumption is they'll just use them
a little bit differently on the TV show
because they're leaning so heavily
into this Batman side of this parody.
probably the funniest moment
from his little montage.
Here is him with the car
in after his follow up broadcast
where he does what the dean as takes
a beat goes to the woods to hump the tree.
then when Sam tries to kill the doctor,
everybody shows up to try and stop him.
And as they're about to either
kill or made him Emma talks him down.
But just as she does
that, there's a huge time jump
of a couple of days
with Marie waking up in Jordan's bed know.
What might have happened
is that the Vought had, another psychic
or someone with psychic powers
that caused them to just forget everything
for a couple of days
or something else could be going on.
normally Vought would try to cover this up
in some way, and an easy way to do
that would be to use a psychic
to just make everybody forget everything
and give them enough time
to scrub the doctor's house.
but the fact that Marie wound up in
Jordan's bed implies that they were active
for the last couple of days
and just don't remember anything.
So let me know in the comments
what you think happened to them,
what this missing
three days was all about.
then there's not that funny and credit
scene of Missy Elliot song with Tek Knight
trying to stick it in the hand dryer
somebody call that dude a doctor
there were a bunch of Easter Eggs
and references
mostly to Tek Knight in the episode
Is there any that you spotted
that I didn't talk about in the video?
Just write them below in the comments
and my Episode 5 video we'll post
next week after my Loki Season 2 Video.
My Loki
Season 2 Episode 2 Trailer Video
We'll post next click here for my full
Loki Season 2 Episode 1 Video and
click here for my Ahsoka Season 2 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!